In this class we'll use five main learning strategies. First, Learning by
Example. Almost every lesson of this class starts with an example of the type of
reasoning we want you to learn. The example that runs throughout the lesson,
could demonstrate that reasoning. Second, Learning by Doing. In most lessons,
the lesson will end with a multi-part exercise, where you are doing the exact
reasoning that you learned in that lesson. There's first you see an example,
then you do a similar example yourself. Third, Project-Based Learning.
The class is largely structured around a series of challenging projects. And
you will frequently be asked to relate each lesson you learn, to the projects in
the class. Personalized learning. Personalization permeates throughout this
course. You can watch the lessons in any order you choose, and at your own pace.
You can choose which concepts to focus on, and everything the assignments.
You'll receive personal feedback on every exercise throughout the course.
Fifth, Learning by Reflection. At the conclusion of each lesson,
you'll be asked to reflect on what you learned in that particular lesson.
At the conclusion of each project, you'll write a designed report that will
reflect on the experiments that you did as part of the project. We'll also use
other learning strategies as needed, such as collaborative learning.